let's hear from some people in the
audience we take calls on the friday
show via discord you can find the
discord at davidpakman.com
discord the discord is free it is free
to join it is free in every way and it
is how you can reach me
let's hear from some folks starting with
brittany in austin brittany am i correct
that that's austin texas
yeah that's correct welcome to the show
good um i'm assuming you can hear
everything fine oh you're coming through
perfectly a little bit echoey but uh i'm
guessing you're you know in like an
italian shower or something like that
echoey that's really weird okay well um
i know you stated that many times you
believe the justice department should
prosecute donald trump if the evidence
points to illegal behavior sure um but i
worry about a scenario where they do
prosecute but ultimately the evidence
just isn't sufficient enough to convict
and how the end result could play out
for negatively for americans so like
and donald trump is accused of crimes
that ultimately result in a lack of
conviction for those crimes i think this
could be potentially catastrophic
because right now with the work from the
january 6 commission while donald trump
isn't formally convicted of anything we
all know that we all like know and
understand his role in attempting to
submerge subvert a democratic election
but if a case is presented and none of
the charges stick
i'm worried that public perception may
shift about january 6 and republicans
could use this as an opportunity to try
similar things in the future and under
the guise that it wasn't illegal and it
wasn't i was just curious i tend to
agree with you brittany i think and this
is why i've said
if the evidence points in that direction
that is the most important thing if the
evidence justifies
and listen prosecutors it's not like we
need to tell prosecutors
you should really only do this if you
think you can get a conviction or at
least a plea deal on on guilty pro
that's how prosecutors operate they
understand that and sometimes it's to a
fault and sometimes cases aren't
prosecuted because prosecutors have
limited time limited resources and they
want to get wins so that's a known issue
but all of that being said i agree with
you if trump is charged
and there's not even like a guilty plea
deal whatever slap on the risk you've
got to at least get that if you don't
get that if you have an acquittal or
charges are dropped it it is an absolute
and total disaster they will use it for
a decade and it will set everything good
back for a very long time and put at
risk future elections as you astutely
point out
yeah prosecution aside i definitely
think that we need to make sure the case
is strong enough before we
support um prosecuting because i just
get really worried about um those
charges not sticking but yeah thanks for
answering my question how's austin these
days you know austin is a popular target
for people to say oh it's ruined the the
liberals of ruined austin
um
i mean i love austin is the only place
in texas i would live because me too i'm
not into the into the government um but
it's really hot so just be aware of that
fair all right brittany thank you so
much for the call
there is brittany from austin texas